given the cost of a hardcover book the
price of it typically hovers around $25
many consumers ask their book dealers
when will the paperback be out so let's
just think about this given the cost of
a hardcover book so this is what we're
talking about we're talking about the
cost of a hardcover book the price of it
typically hovers around $25 so they're
trying to give us a little bit more
information on the cost of a hardcover
book but this this clause here that they
gave us the price of it typically hovers
around $25 is is very wordy and it's
very clumsy when they're really saying
you've given the cost of a hardcover
book which typically is or hovers around
$25 so I'm gonna look for a phrase it's
closer to which typically hovers around
$25 so let's look at our choices so the
first choice is always exactly as they
wrote it here so I'm gonna rule that one
out because it really does feel very
wordy and very clumsy given the cost of
a hardcover book and typically it covers
a tape it hovers at a price around $25
well once again this is this is a little
bit this is a little bit strangely
worded and typically it hovers we really
want to have a a relative pronoun which
here you know we're talking about the
cost which does something which hovers
around $25 so and twice he actually
seems to do the trick for us given the
cost of a hardcover book which and what
is the relative is the relative pronoun
which referring to was referring to the
cost of a hardcover book which typically
hovers around $25 many consumers ask
their book dealers when will the
paperback be out well this one feels
really good conveys the exact meaning
that we want it's much shorter which
typically hovers is much shorter than
the price of it typically hovers and
it's it's a lot less convoluted so si is
definitely where I'd like to go now
let's just look at the other choices in
that it typically hovers given the cost
of a hardcover book in that it typically
hovers well once again you're just
really need to say which typically
hovers in that you're doing this
prepositional phrase it's it's a very
strange thing just to
give a little bit of a extra context of
the cost so I'm gonna rule that one out
they typically hover so this one day
you're talking about something in the
plural and the cost is singular the cost
of a hardcover book at least the way
it's being referred to so we're not
saying day this is this this is a this
is this is plural while the thing that
we are that the pronoun the relative Pro
Tour that well in this case just the
pronoun is referring to is is singular
the cost singular so that's why this one
right over here doesn't make any sense
so yeah given the cost of a hardcover
book which typically hovers around $25
many consumers ask their book dealers
when will the paperback be out that
feels very good